au québec un groupe de jeunes noirs
rassemblés dans un parc à la tombée de
la nuit on appelle ça
les amis québécois
comment elle est reçue cette pub là
autour de vous
c'est sûr qu'on est un peu perplexe
pierre sont vaval est intervenant
communautaire auprès de jeunes de
rivière des prairies à montréal il a
l'impression que ces publicités
entretiennent des stéréotypes c'est
louche les jeunes oies dans un parc au
coucher du soleil
oui c'est normal que vous penser ça mais
c'est des québécois je sais pas le
concept pour lequel je m'étais engagé
lorsqu'on m'a approché pour réaliser
cette pub selon le réalisateur le
gouvernement a décidé d'ajouter le mot
québécois sans son accord et lui demande
maintenant de retirer la publicité c'est
devenu une campagne politique pour moi
c'est devenu une campagne nationaliste
c'est devenu une campagne d' intégration
plutôt qu'une campagne de
sensibilisation
qui essaie de dire dans ces annonces la
race comme un effort mais ce peut être
un effort maladroit au québec un groupe
de blancs sur pays rassemblés dans un
bureau de la capitale pour faire une
publicité anti raciste on appelle ça une
mauvaise idée québécois le malaise est
tel que des humoristes en ont fait des
parodies on veut montrer aux québécois
que vous êtes comme nous non mais moi je
suis québécoise oui c'est sûr que vous
êtes québécoise les vrais québécois je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
sont senti beaucoup mieux représentée
par nos parodies que par les grèves
publicité parce que au moins nous en
parler des vrais enjeux un homme
originaire d'amérique du sud avec des
tatouages qui court dans la rue de voir
qu'il ya une volonté concrète de parler
de cet enjeu là c'est une bonne chose
mais en même temps quand tu parle de
quelque chose comme ça mais ça n'engage
comme gouvernement
quand on a on en arrive à la parodie
comme ça il faut retirer ses publicités
et puis en tirant ses publicités la ce
enverrait un message
le ministre responsable de la lutte
contre le racisme benoit charette ne
semble pas avoir l'intention de les
retirer dans un courriel son bureau
explique que la volonté est de combattre
les préjugés envers les minorités
visibles et ils croient atteindre cet
objectif ici sébastien desrosiers radio
canada morrell